كنا في حي صعب للغاية ،
كان هذا هو العراق ، كان هذا في
العراق ، وكان ذلك أثناء الانتفاضة
، كانت القاعدة تكتسب قوة ، ومن
الصعب أن تأخذ الشباب الأمريكيين الذين
نشأوا بالفعل بدرجة عالية من
الثقة ببعضهم البعض من الجميع.  لقد
التقوا ، إنه لأمر مدهش بالنسبة لي مدى انفتاح
الأمريكيين إذا بدت وكأنني فقدت
الوصول إلى الاستوديو الخاص بك اليوم ، فلن
أقف عشر ثوانٍ على زاوية شارع نيويورك
دون أن يقترب مني خمسة أشخاص
يطلبون المساعدة في إرشادي إلى حيث  يجب
أن أذهب ، إنها الطريقة التي نشأت بها
، كان علي أن آخذ 18 جندي مشاة أطفال يبلغون من العمر 18 عامًا
،
هكذا حصلوا على أسمائهم ويقولون إنه
يجب أن تكون مستعدًا الآن لبعض
الأشخاص الخائنين الحقيقيين ، لذا نذهب إلى ذلك
ذلك المثلث السني ، وعلى سبيل المثال ،
كان لدي 29 بحارًا ومشاة البحرية حولي ،
مدافع المدفعية ، وسائقي المساعدون لي ،
وهذا النوع من الأشياء في مركباتي الصغيرة الأربع أو
الخمس ، وأكثر من أربعة أشهر 17 من
أصل 29 أو قتلوا أو أصيبوا بجروح من حولي
عندما يكون لديك  هذا المستوى من العنف
يحدث عندما نقاتل في أماكن
مثل الفلوجة ، عليك أن تقوي
قواتك في أوقات عصيبة للغاية ، لكن
في نفس الوقت استعرت تقريبًا كل
اقتباساتي الجيدة من الآخرين بالطريقة التي
اقترضتها كريستين من
يقسم الأطباء أولاً ألا يضروا إذا كان
عليك أن تطلق النار في سوق مزدحم لكي تقتل إرهابيًا ،
فلا تغامر بضرب امرأة أو طفل
يلاحقه في يوم آخر ويقبض عليه
ولكن لا تغامر بذلك.
نحاول دائمًا تخفيف حدة العنف لأنك
تذكر أن كل ساحة معركة هي أيضًا
ميدان إنساني وإذا نسيت
أنك تتوقف عن حمل
بصمة أمريكا في القيم الأمريكية للحرب
في الحرب ولا تريد أن
يعود الشباب إلى الوطن الذين لا يفعلون ذلك.  تريد أن تنظر
في المرآة أو ما فعلوه